- Say hello to Diego Calva everybody.
- Hello.
Hi.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
Diego, I'm gonna lead
with you're so talented.
I love this film so much.
You did such an amazing job.
And also happy New Year.
- Thank you.
Happy New Year everyone.
- How, how did you celebrate the New Year?
What did you do?
- Well, I like to spend it
with my mother and my family.
And in Mexico we have this tradition,
we eat 12 grapes and you have to-
- [Kelly] Oh, I've done that.
- to do a wish for every grape.
But last year was so incredible
for me that honestly, I was wishes-less.
- [Kelly] Aw.
- Everything came true.
- [Kelly] That's a beautiful thing.
I've actually done that once.
You just reminded me.
I was in Mexico once for New Year's,
and they, they passed out the grapes
at the restaurant we were
at and I was like, what?
And I just like grapes
and I like wishes, too.
So I kept going.
I was like, I'm into this.
- How, how many am I allowed?
- [Kelly] I know.
I'm like, can I have more?
I wish for more wishes.
Well, Diego, speaking of family
we have them to thank for
introducing you to movies, right?
- Yeah.
First of all, Margot,
you look great as always.
As always.
- So do you, honey.
- Yeah.
My grandfather and my grandmother
they used to take me to the movies.
Like, that was my, my, my
activity during the weekends.
And it was like a very
special moment, you know,
for a kid like going to the
theater and, and all that.
- Yeah.
- [Diego] And I remember before I was able
to read like the subtitles super fast.
They love me so more,
that they whisper the whole
movie in my ear, you know,
they read the, the subtitles and whisper
like Batmam just said this,
or Superman just said that.
Things like that.
- [Kelly] Aw.
That's a lot of love, cause
that's a lot of translating.
But your character in Babylon
has a similar love of movies
so I love and know your character
but everybody else doesn't.
So you wanna tell him a bit about Manny?
- Well, Manny, first of all,
he's still my best friend.
I think I'm going to be
with that guy for the rest of my life.
But then Manny is a dreamer.
Manny is a guy that he
really wants to be part
of something bigger than what he knows.
He, he, and for him
that something is movies and
he's going to do anything.
You know, he, he doesn't
care if he has to clean
if he has to, to bring the
coffee, to cook like anything.
He just want to be part
of that beautiful party.
He's been seeing from the distance
that is like Hollywood and movie making.
- [Kelly] Like I feel
like I was telling Margot
in the commercial break, I was like, it's
I feel like Manny is how everyone
starts when you come here.
You're just such a dreamer
and you're just wide-eyed
and, and it's a beautiful
thing that, that innocence
like coming to Hollywood or you know, LA,
but so Diego what was it like
when you first met Brad Pitt?
What was that like?
Because in the, in the movie
it's kind of funny cause
he plays this big huge star
which not a stretch and
you know, and this is
like a big huge film
for you to do with him.
So what was that like, like
having the scene with him
like working with him at first?
- Well, I wanted to
tell the story of how I
I met Brad because with Damien everything
is so meta-fictional and Damien took care
at least with my character and with me
like to try like weird situations.
So I was in Mexico City
and Damien called me
and he said, Diego, I'm going
to direct this commercial.
Brad is the lead of the commercial.
I think it's a good idea if you come
to, to Los Angeles and meet him.
Also, there's going to be a bunch
of people that is going
to work in the commercial
that are part of the crew of the movie.
So I think it's a win-win
kind of situation.
So I flew to Los Angeles
and right before we started
like shooting the commercial
Damien told me he wanted me to pretend
that I was his assistant
or a PA on the commercial.
So I worked for one day, I
had like my backpack full
of Coca-Colas and I was literally giving
like Coca-Colas to everyone
and, 'Hey Mr. Brad
Pitt, you need something
like a coffee or anything?
I can, I can help you.'
And day two of the shooting,
Mary Zophres, the costume designer,
she, she did Babylon with us,
also, she was doing the commercial.
She came to Brad and said like,
'Hey Brad have you met Diego?
He's going to play Manuel in Babylon.'
And Brad just turned to see Damien
and to see me and he said, like,
somebody had something to explain.
Damien what's going on?
And I, he's a very, a very funny way
to meet Brad Pit, actually.
I think the shock was in his
side, not in mine, this case.
- [Kelly] I know, I love that.
He was like, wait, what?
The guy with the Coca-Cola, right?
So Diego, you also stayed, this I love,
you, actually stayed with Margo
and her husband while filming.
Right?
- We're roomies.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [Diego] Yep.
- [Kelly] What was that like?
- [Diego] I said this before,
but I still very grateful
and I really appreciate
that because sometimes Hollywood
could be a lonely place.
You know-
- [Kelly] A lot of times.
- [Diego] Especially when you're
like the newcomer or like the new kid
and you don't have like your
friends and your family there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I was working on Babylon all day
and then going back to the hotel
and sleeping by myself, like, you know
it could, could be like a
tricky, lonely situation.
So I think Mar Margo saw that on me
and she just invited me
and it was incredible
because for a couple of weeks you feel
like, like home again
and you are not like lonely
and just like sharing,
you know, like playing cards
or, or playing with Belle.
By the way, Belle is the
most beautiful people
you will ever, ever see.
- [Margot] That's my dog.
- That's your dog.
I was like, is that the pit bull?
- Yeah.
She's getting so much airtime today.
- [Diego] That situation is very helpful.
- [Margot] No, he's
Diego's the best roommate
because yeah my dog loves him.
So it, we were like
co-parenting my pit bull
and we were on the same hours
we're doing all these crazy hours at work.
And so we were, you know, it's
actually the juxtaposition
between our day life and our nightlife.
It's like a sign of, you know
a show of domesticity when we get home
and at work it's like
crazy having fight scenes
and doing these scenes
where we're doing tons
of drugs and partying and
then we'd get home and be like
have you fed Belle?
I'll take her for a walk.
Do we, do we need more milk?
I'll get milk tomorrow.
Okay, great.
And then we go, go back
to work and it's like rah.
It's great.
- I, I love it.
I just think it's a cool
thing too, just to like
you know for the couple
weeks or whatever it was
just to be able to like,
you know, hang with people
outside of work that you're,
you have this chemistry
on set and you're building
something beautiful.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's long lasting.
And that's a, that's a really cool thing.
I thought that was like my
favorite part of this interview.